[Music]
you may not have seen a lot of stephen
crowder lately
why is that where where has this
international man of mystery gone
is it because he has covid i don't know
maybe he
does have the sniffles and he's got a
box of tissues on his desk is it because
he's gone to the other side of the world
no it's because youtube
is taking him down like they've been
doing more and more in recent days
what did steven do now we will find out
stephen thank you for being here
thank you very thank you for having me
sir i apologize that i sound like like
hunter uh biden on a parm bender but
i'm very sick the only thing that i know
it's not is
covid because of many many tests that
i've done
wow that's true i'm sure you've you've
taken a bunch of tests and now
you know even if you want to walk into
like a starbucks i think you've got to
get three
negative covid tests so you do but you i
actually
didn't remember that anyone could get
sick with anything else
over the past rather than covet i know
no believe me i was in the same boat
turns out the flu is still a thing and
it turns turns out that says pneumonia
bronchitis these things still exist as a
matter of fact
it's almost more likely for some of you
out there
to get it depending where you are and
depending on your age demographic you
know if you're a young healthy person
you might be more likely to experience
these symptoms like i have where you
know
if i could check off a list hey which
symptoms of everything that i have you
know
the throat that feels like the device
from seven had been jammed into it
the uh the the nasal drip or a slight
loss of taste and smell
i would pick that that's what i would
pick yes you you but
wow i'm so upset that not only are you
going to get yourself kicked off youtube
now that you have suggested that some
people are less likely than others to
get covered you're going to
get me kicked off of youtube too and
then and then where are we going to be
i know how how dare we suggest it it's
almost it's almost as risky
as suggesting that if people are
vaccinated they don't need to wear masks
here we go
and retroactively retroactively we don't
fix those bands do we we don't fix the
bands of people who said that they were
removed from social media platforms
until fauci said well you know it really
it really was theta because i didn't
want to send the wrong message okay
great well i think we sent the wrong
message by banning people who were
actually following the science and who
were right
you know it this brings up there was a
fact check i think it was
i forget if it was politified i guess it
was politifact they came out and they
said
oh my god i'm going to get kovid just
from sitting oh gosh
that's sorry i can feel it over here uh
i
i saw this fact check where someone said
early on
it looks like the wuhan institute of
virology was associated with this this
leak
and they got a big fact check from
politifact
this is wrong seven zillion pinocchios
and then they had to put an
editor's note on the fact check and they
said oh actually yeah maybe it was
where's the where's the apology where's
the take putting them back on youtube
where's the
uh reinstituting their social media
platforms i mean this is right
i don't i don't think it was coved that
got you booted this time can you tell us
anything about
why you're off youtube right now can i
tell you anything
uh yes uh a few things so first off let
me preface it with this because
you and i both know that they're you
want to do your show
i want to do my show there are some
people who thrive off of just social
media drama who
oh they have a twitter temporary
suspension and they want
this is not that like we've done
hundreds of shows
we do hours of content you know
we get more viewers on a live show than
jimmy kimmel then
um then jimmy fallon okay that's what i
want to do
this is different we have uh submitted a
notice we are filing a lawsuit with
youtube and an immediate
uh injunction request of injunction
because as you know on youtube
if you have three strikes your account
is gone forever
yeah okay so we we had the vox
apocalypse this happened a while back
and they found that we violated no
policies right so they demonetized us
then they re-monetize us and they
demonetize us and we've always said
your sandbox okay your rules 230 may
have something to say about it
but in this case actually covid was one
of them so uh the first
i don't remember the exact order but for
people who out there who aren't paying
attention and we're still broadcasting
by the way live
at uh lotto with crowder.com mug club
and uh the free content is available on
rumble right now
until we're able to stream back on
youtube and remains to be seen
the first strike which wasn't a strike
which was a warning
was about election about voter fraud i
should say because
we made very clear we never discussed
mass election fraud we never said the
ghost of hugo chavez rigged the dominion
voting machines and donald trump was
the rightful uh you know president who
won reelection
what we did do when it became a joke
with my lawyer was i said what look just
like amy klobuchar just like elizabeth
warren just like jimmy carter where we
talk
they talked about they had commissions
to say hey voter fraud
which can occur is one of the biggest
threats to our national security to our
national democracy that was
them yeah yeah and it occurs more with
mail-in voting they said that
obama said okay can we talk yes exactly
ask can we say that yes
can we cross-reference voters with the
current voter rolls and the addresses
that don't exist and if we go on google
earth and show that it doesn't exist as
an address can i just talk about those
he said nope because google earth is not
up to date i said what if i said interns
that day with a copy of that day's
newspaper live on camera to show that
it's an overpass or an empty lot
double triple confirmed he said if
you're willing to do that we're sure
fine and we actually booked tickets to
nevada and michigan and did it
that was removed okay now we didn't get
a real reason they just said uh
well you know this is violates election
policy i believe that was the warning
then one of them was for covid one was a
warning one was a heart strike that they
should have been considered heart
strikes you know listen
tomato i say um you know uh orwellian
yeah
so the covid one we did a one-year
anniversary
to uh 15 days to flatten the curve and
we went through the sequence of all
of the science so for example we had a
montage of fauci saying
don't wear a mask a mask is actually
worse because people touch their face
and touching their face
and then we had them saying do wear a
mask with the surgeon general saying
stop buying mass and then saying do buy
them out then we had them saying
double masking is unnecessary you guys
should double mask double masking
so we went through all of this right and
keep in mind i think we're the only show
that does this we provide all of our
references like a bibliography
at loudouthcredit.com every day every
single show wow our sources for this
episode were primarily the cdc in the
world health organization
and they're never specific and these
aren't really violations but i believe
the statement that got us into trouble
and i'm sorry hopefully doesn't get
anyone in trouble was something along
the lines of and so i will make sure
that it's not specific but
we brought up an image of the cdc uh
mortality charts and said covet is
significantly more lethal than the flu
to old people and we need to recognize
that and treat it properly
for some reason it's significantly less
lethal than the flu
exclusively to young people yeah yeah
yeah
that was it that was going against uh
that was considered medical
misinformation
this is the sort of thing you know my
wife was pregnant during covid
we'd go into the doctors and we said
gosh do we need to be worried about this
for the baby
because you know flu is actually kind of
a big deal if you're pregnant
but the doctors all of them said no
actually for whatever reason covet is
not really a threat to the babies or to
pregnant mothers
you don't need to worry about it as much
as you would for something like the flu
i mean this is not some
kooky conspiracy theory i just went
through i mean my wife is pregnant with
twins right now
and i am up in the den in the far wing
of the house
like dracula can't like castlevania
version dracula you know where i'm
slightly charming but still a little bit
intimidating
and i just emerged from my coffin to do
the show and hack into a mug
this is we're going through this right
now we just had that conversation
that conversation could result in a
strike
or a ban wow now the final this is the
one that just happened that was the
second strike and again i
you know we don't have specific answers
here's it's one thing to have a rule
book
people to understand it and they break
the rules fair ball you know what i mean
this happens all the time in sports
where you go i don't agree with the call
but okay it's in the rules you know this
happens like an mma you grab my shorts
you're not allowed but the ref didn't
call it
i have to accept the results that's not
what's going on right now the recent
strike
was let me be as clear as i'm trying to
be as succinct as possible so i don't
bore people
remember the the police officer uh the
hero who saved a young girl of color in
ohio who was about to be stabbed
no i i'm sorry i only remember the
vicious monster
who wouldn't even allow that young
wonderful girl to stab the other girl to
death and who
was imposing his white supremacy on her
yeah yes ed furlong and a bomber jacket
yes correct
um no so we we talked about this on air
and i said not only not only do i think
this was a justified
shooting i think it was unnecessary
shooting the police officer i think it'd
be an abdication of duty if you don't
shoot someone
while they are attempting to penetrate
someone's flesh
with a knife yes um and this was
celebrating you know and
by the way i make no apologies sometimes
people go it's always a tragedy no no
look
this is not one of those equivocations
sure we'd wish that people wouldn't lose
their lives but i actually think that
once someone has made a decision to put
someone else's life in danger the happy
ending as the innocent civilian
is saved lawfully by the police officer
that was considered
broadly harassment bullying because of
reveling in the death
of apparently mikaya bryant which which
we did not do now
look people need to understand that as
comedians as a comedian
this is a comedy show there's a
difference between when we're joking
about things when we're covering stories
that's why we provide
our references but this is this is um
not about what we're doing i think a lot
of people can sort of you know you look
at like alex jones at one point
was was d platform and i disagree with
alex jones on a whole lot i didn't think
the deserved bd platform i think a lot
of people can separate themselves from
what they view as extremism look i am
basic pumpkin spice latte basic
conservatism a christian conservative
who came to notoriety because amy
schumer attacked me for talking about
how i wasn't having sex until i was
married
and these points of view youtube is
saying you cannot say
that the science matters that
two-year-olds shouldn't mask
according to the cdc you cannot say that
voter fraud occurs on an individual
level and agree with amy klobuchar
elizabeth warren you
are not welcome to say on our platform
good for you police officer for in a
fraction of a second
placing a perfect shot to save someone's
life that is saying if they remove us
here from youtube and we have good
reason to believe that they're looking
for other
potential violations because these
aren't actual violations as far as we
know we really haven't gotten the
specificity
this is tantamount to saying half the
country
your points of view are not welcome on
this platform there is no extremist here
this is really important because
i guess the line here that they're
pushing is you know you your joke went
too far about makia brian but what
you're saying is no it's not a joke
i'm at the same point on my show i said
yeah it's sad you know it's sad that
this is a fallen world and people do bad
things
and they face consequences when they do
it but this is a
good conclusion when someone is about to
be stabbed
it is good that a cop goes in and saves
that person's life there's nothing
that's a joke about that and the other
thing here that when i see the coverage
every time you get suspended or they try
to de-platform you you see it in media
matters or any of the other leftist
organizations
they'll go out and they'll say far-right
extremist
radical right-winger stephen crowder and
i think you know i don't
they're obviously being disingenuous and
dishonest when it's media matters or
right-wing watch or any of those other
groups but i bet a lot of
other people out there might not realize
how pumpkin spice you are they might not
realize i mean i look i spend a lot of
my day
reading far radical leftist content
watching far radical leftist content
and watching far radical right wing
content i mean really
out there stuff and i'm and then some
stuff in the middle too
you are i say this it's going to sound
like an insult almost
you i understand what you're about to
say you are about as mainstream as it
gets
if they go after you they are it's not
like it's the fringe radical right
if they go after you and they
de-platform you what they are saying is
anyone in this country who identifies as
conservative
is no longer welcome here that is
exactly what
and i hate to because i don't want to be
a martyr i want to do the show but this
is
this program is the biggest conservative
program that's ever existed on it's ever
existed on a new media platform period
yeah
um certainly on youtube billions of
plays
and look i defy people point out to me
my most extreme
right-wing view ending the drug war
yeah what heartbeat bills for abortion a
flat
tax yeah non-interventionism unless our
country's security is at stake uh
free open markets where people have to
be transparent
i don't know i couldn't point to any
radical points of view what i
what i would say is what they probably
try and says well we didn't like the way
you said it
and the only thing this didn't come from
from uh youtube as far as i know
people were mad because they said well
you you joked about mckay bryant being
overweight
first off maybe i did but the statement
that i made was
at this time people need to understand
at this moment in history when we went
out there and we did this stream for
example
lebron james had just tweeted out you're
next to this police officer and the
story was a police officer showed up
mckay bryant
called the police and he showed up and
shot her
that was it and she didn't have a knife
so we had to correct it and it was a 16
year old girl and i said look
this isn't a 15 this is a 230 pound
woman who was midstep and that matters
that matters i don't remember if it was
joe lewis it might have been marvin
hagler who said listen
the size of someone matters regardless
of age he said i remember he was talking
about i think it might have been marvin
hagler i could be wrong
or he was about to fight someone who
they thought was a stepping stone they
said what are you saying to people who
say your opponent doesn't have a shot he
said
he's a 200 pound man i don't care who
you a 200-pound man hits you
he has a shot yeah and that's what it is
very relevant yes it's relevant how
police approach it
just like it's relevant how the immune
system of a four-year-old
reacts differently to a novel virus than
a 64 year old
and people tell us that we need to
follow the science we need to follow the
truth
well where are your sources uh rachel
maddow new york times we always try to
be as transparent as possible
and it's look could i go off and and do
something like mud club sure
there are ways to make a living when
you're not on these platforms and i hope
that there's an alternative at some
point where
people in the future can make a living
but i started this in 2009 i started
youtube in 2006.
started doing political videos in 2008
or 2009 with a blue bed sheet in my den
there was no money okay there were no
conservatives now i know there's been
sort of a meme
factory sort of people talk about alt
right this is long before that now this
is a business i'm soon to be a father of
two
with 12 people 12 to 15 people who i
employ depending on the day depending on
the interns who are here
and um i don't know that there can ever
be another
young stephen crowder coming up i don't
know that there could ever be another
rush limbaugh because
the entire town square the entire
digital town square is controlled
by effectively three companies facebook
you know google alphabet uh youtube and
twitter
and certainly then if you include amazon
and apple who also control the app
stores
and the ability to even get a competing
application up there
i don't know if if you're not allowed to
say hey officer
not even blanket back the blue hey
officer thanks for saving that girl's
life and shooting uh
that that woman while she was trying to
stab her if you're not allowed to say
that on youtube
i don't see how anyone could censor
themselves to come up
and uh and carry the torch behind us and
that's really what is
scary to me and by the way let's say now
you're just going to do your show it's
only going to be mug club it's all going
to be private you
you'll go on to some private website and
and by the way they'll try to shut that
down too just like they shut parlor off
of amazon web services
but then let's say okay you find some
other server and you're going to host it
and that's great you're going to be on
you know steven crowder's special
secretmugclub.club.mug.org or whatever
and they can't get at you okay it is
simply the case that even if you bring
over a huge portion of your audience
that is going to be ghettoizing your
extremely mainstream conservative
content
and so you're gonna you'll get you'll
get to keep some of your viewers
but by the way the the whole point of
youtube or these other social media
platforms that have gotten a critical
mass and now control
the flow of information around the
internet is discovery
so sure maybe you get to eke out a
living and maybe some of your most
die-hard fans
who can follow you and keep track of all
this stuff and they're very tech savvy
they'll follow you
but it's okay the big blob the liberal
establishment's fine with that
because no no one else is going to
discover you and they'll keep their
control over the information
and then they'll go and write new york
times columns bitching about an echo
chamber
right they'll say we need to stop the
radicalization so you got rid of the guy
who wrote about
not having sex until marriage you got
rid of the guy who said you know what
uh actually you already do have to pass
a background check to uh legally
purchase a firearm
you got rid of the guy who said i come
from a country where we don't have a
first amendment and so the first
amendment is really important to me
and defended liberals who i do not like
and their right to speak freely you got
rid of that
like you said basic mainstream basic
conservatism right seasonal starbucks
um and then you complain about an echo
chamber whereas people
who don't believe that the police should
exist
at all nor nor prison systems exist at
all
people say oh you're taking fringe no
i'm taking united states representatives
in rashida to labe
in alexandria castro cortez in illinois
people who joe biden has praised these
are mainstream leftists
and they hold far more extreme views
yeah
far more extreme views um and it's just
ironic to me that then they complain
about
an echo chamber but really look i've
always said this before is is
when they demonetize us everyone else
made a big deal about that and i said
i don't care obviously i care right i
run a business and it does and it hurts
everybody here
but i say if you don't have to uh
youtube they don't have to pay us for
the content now that being said
sometimes ads were run anyway i'm like
well someone's making some money
also i've run ads on youtube and they
say well advertisers don't want to be
associated with your content and i go
home
when i run ads i can't run my videos as
ads and the kind of content
i would like to sponsor you preclude me
as both an advertiser
and you preclude me as a content creator
who are these who are these people
making well they have three different
sets of standards they have community
guidelines okay
this is determined by youtube which is
if you're bullying harassing you know i
just think it should be the actual
speech code laws if you're
breaking the law that's how simple it
should be then they have
uh advertiser friendly guidelines well
who determines that well we know it's
not really the advertiser certainly not
me i'm bad
you're an ad i'm an advertiser right
yeah yeah we've never been pulled
so that's also determined by youtube and
then there's a third category now
borderline content which isn't a
violation of policy
but they have other think tanks and
organizations and
strategic business partners who
determine if something is borderline and
that's where this rests
and from what i understand they said
well you didn't violate
the guidelines per se but in totality
maybe there's a pattern of whatever it
is
lgbtq aip or racism or something you
know because this is a new thing by the
way
i don't know if you know this we've
always known that you know for example
blackface
horrible you don't do blackface that's
something you shouldn't do that's not
new we've ever since we've grown up we
know white people don't do blackface
there's no
argument about that trudeau
notwithstanding that's his
own face northum northam would be
another one or joy behar
or jimmy kimmel or yeah but but
i guess we don't do it it's what you're
saying no we know that you don't do it
but what's very new is you can't do an
impression of someone
who happens to be black well that's very
new really you've had
white people yeah they go you're doing
black voice black voice
what yeah black voice i mean i was just
watching a show life and times of tim on
each one of my favorite shows it's a
white
guy playing a black female hooker on the
show it's a voice yeah that's what they
switch out of poo so now they try and
say retroactively
well this is now this is racist you
can't do a lisp because it might be
mocking lgbt
they just keep changing the rules and
act as though it's the same as using the
n-word or blackface
and it's not and i think that people
need to be very clear about that and to
be clear about it you just need to be
able to it's not hard
well there's a there's a historical
connotation with blackface and minstrel
shows the n-word was created from the
ground up to oppress it's not because we
view the world through the lens of
oppressor
and the oppressed it's because the word
was designed to hurt yeah
other words have been changed and
morphed and reappropriated so that
there's a a war
against language and uh so my issue
sorry to go back to the point here
this is this blue head this brings up
actually a pretty important point though
because i remember when they canceled
aunt jemima
they said you know aunt jemima is racist
and i said well she
because she's a black woman i said well
you can't have black women on products
now they say no it's
because uh that that woman is offensive
i said well you know as a black
model who portrayed aunt jemima they
said yeah but that was
she didn't realize how oppressive it was
and i said i looked up and i said
well actually you know it was a black
comedian who
created the character aunt jemima billy
cursans who was a minstrel performer
he wasn't a white guy in blackface he
was a black guy he was the writer who
popularized this character aunt jemima
so now you've got some
some 27 year old almost certainly i
don't have evidence of this but i
i'd bet the farm on it a white chick
working in some marketing department
in the the company that owns aunt jemima
saying
that we need to cancel a black actress a
black character and a black writer
because it would be offensive to black
people that she's feeling on behalf as a
white woman
and not only that we've said hey white
people who by the way were
the largest consumers of aunt jemima
you're not allowed to be comforted
by a southern black lady which by the
way it was the reason it was marketable
is because there were enough white
people in this country who thought that
was appealing and thought aunt jemima
was likable that it was
it was comfort food if you're a racist
you don't have aunt jemima on your table
you don't but guess what if you're a
racist
you never have to see aunt jemima on
your table again win one for the races
and the issue so the issue here i mean i
look i feel like i'm living in a
parallel universe here
and uh whitlock actually jason whitlock
made the point he said i think the
reason that
people like myself or people like you
get in trouble where people say that's
racist because
there is not even a shred of racism
when there's no shred of racism in your
personal life you feel free
to communicate authentically you're not
worried about the landmines because
i mean we have in this office alone we
have what we have four asians
we have a biracial we have uh we have
pretty sure we have we have
pretty sure we have two gays but i don't
want to out them here um we have
we have people who didn't even speak the
language until a couple of years ago
um this is a really surprisingly diverse
office place
and it's not even an issue so the issue
here with with youtube though is i
didn't care about the demonetization
because i was saying you don't have to
pay me if you
that's fine yeah let us know what the
viola they wreck they they did a full
audit of everything and so these aren't
violations but we would request that you
you know
maybe get rid of these things we were
public we told people youtube wants us
to get rid of these
it wasn't a spotify situation where they
just disappeared we let people know
these are youtube's rules we're going to
stay there
and they re-monetize us we didn't
necessarily know why then they
demonetized us and now we're at a point
we're going
hold on what's the violation here yeah
and they're not being clear about it
there is no
other course of action at this point to
maintain a livelihood for
everyone here um you know and my future
children
and all we want to do is a show that's
not even a strong pg-13 a show that
could run
on on fcc broadcasts in on most days
i'll i'll i'll give you that right of
course because
it would seem to me what they're proving
now in big tech
is this old line you hear it in new york
which is you can indict a ham sandwich
you can they i don't think they saw a
violation and they said that's it that's
the line i think
they they decided they're going to get
you
this is enough we've had enough crowder
so we're gonna get you okay he didn't
really cross the line okay he didn't
he didn't violate this policy well now
we have this kind of ridiculous category
called
borderline content the whole reason that
you have the guidelines
is so that you're either on one side of
it or the other so if you have
borderline content you
you obliterate the the point of the
guidelines themselves but okay yeah
we'll use that and it's a little broad
in any way
we'll find something in the meantime
you're suspended
that's what it is right yes yes and i
just want to make sure i have to because
i want to quote directly here for
for uh for effect the exact terminology
so maybe you need to have your sensor
button of stephen colbert
and of samantha b because i've had these
conversations where they say well
do you need to do this segment we have a
segment called what a piece of [ __ ] and
it usually involves a terrorist
or maybe don lemon something like that
that's silly right yeah
it's a redundant description but yeah
right exactly
and i said you really shouldn't do that
or you know what you really shouldn't
have accidentally missed
you shouldn't have one time was you
shouldn't have laughed when this
uh transgender individual threw a
lunchbox at you
and ran and tripped over their high
heels when she
was running away and i said okay i can
see how that offends you
but is it anywhere near as close to
calling our sitting president's mouth
putin's
holster or the first lady effectless you
have to use that as a standard
not does this joke offend you it has to
be applied equally and don't try and
conflate
a joke yeah with a point right and uh i
think that's important
it's listen it's tough because we we
make both of those on this show
it's really the only show that does it
the way that we do it's why we've been
incredibly successful and i don't say
that out of arrogance i say it
on my knees uh mr marley i say it on my
knees grateful for the fans that we have
who have supported us
and we've played by the rules as best we
know how and now there are no other
options and i don't want this fight
no one would want this fight i am
absolutely a pat people don't know this
about me
i've never been in a fight do you
realize this in my adult life in a
physical never happened
in a physical fight never it's never
happened not once exhausted
yeah people see the muscles in the gun
and they just say you know what maybe no
no no no no i'll miss and i'll mess with
another guy today no i've been assaulted
and people know that you know i have a
hobby like come and we have i mean for
chronology
and every other week we have a ufc
champion because it's a sport we follow
and we work with
sometimes we train with these people
yeah i've never been in a fight i'm very
much a pacifist but my
my belief is this you avoid it at all
costs
there is nothing anyone can say to me
yeah that will offend me enough
to fight there's nothing anyone can say
about my wife that will offend me enough
to fight now i'm not saying that that
should be the line for everyone but as a
public figure i understand the line is
different for me yeah
however if i get to the point and again
i've never been in a physical
altercation i've been assaulted
meaning i've been assaulted and i have
retreated and not haven't thought about
that
right right but if it's at a point where
i believe that there is no escape
and it is my duty to protect you through
my safety or those around me
have predetermined that it will be as
swift and as effective as possible
to end that threat yeah it's the same
thing with this
lawsuit right now in injunction with
youtube i don't want the fight
you guys can tell us your rules that's
why we have mug club you want us to try
and set
okay i think there will be a
conversation somewhere down the line
about 230 whether you're a publisher or
a platform yeah but
got it but we're at the point now where
there is no other way
to proceed and so we've got to make sure
that people know exactly what is going
on here and this is like you said this
is tantamount to saying
no conservative viewpoints are welcome
on this platform i mean
here's we're talking about the publisher
issue this is separate but i don't think
there's
ever been a more clear example than
president trump people say ex-president
he was removed from all these platforms
while he was president right yeah
he was removed for saying fight like
hell uh which by the way our shirts are
available at creditshop.com anyone who
acts like
anyone who acts like fight like hell is
not a phrase that had been used forever
it's just being dishonest okay um
removed the president of the united
states
the ayatollah is still on twitter
hamas is still on twitter so twitter has
now said
listen we have decided editorially that
donald trump's tweets
are just too far of a bridge for us to
cross which
must mean that they've decided hamas and
ayatollah khamenei
are not yeah they need to be held liable
for that
you can't enjoy the legal protections
and say we're just a platform
when you are clearly making editorial
decisions and that's what's going on
here
i think that kicking trump off and they
all did it right
basically every single social media
platform and and some
technology platforms that aren't even
exactly social media
they all acted independently there's no
collusion even
it was within days of one another and
and to me that was crossing the rubicon
to me that was
yeah it's so that that hipster rasputin
or you know jack dorsey in silicon
valley
that he and these other oligarchs would
ban the duly elected sitting president
whatever you think about the 2020
election
the man was the duly elected sitting
president on january 7th january 8th
and they booted him off so of course
next they're going to go for stephen
crowder steven crowder's got
the biggest conservative show on social
media so what booting him off too
and i love what you said there about
look youtube i don't want this fight
i'm i'm willing to play ball to a
certain degree
i am not the sort of person who says you
ought to be able to say
whatever you want at any time regardless
you know i mean i think we've got
fraud you're not allowed to have uh to
discuss
fraud right in this country you've had
protections against that
from the very beginning a sedition
obscenity direct threats that's not
protected speech
so i'm i'm willing to play ball but
here's
but here's something that's even more
concerning uh uh mr nils
and i know you probably know this but a
lot of people skim over it
do you know why citizen journalism is
going to be dead why
but i got into it with john stossel
about this he wouldn't be able to do the
stuff that he used to do on 2020.
um because the things that you just
meant these are laws
for example not hate speech that's not a
real thing but a direct threat
or a direct call to violence or if we're
talking about slander libel
yeah they don't follow those laws on
youtube
a single-party consensus what does that
mean you're in a state where you have
the right
to record in other words that's how you
record corrupt politicians
engaging in corrupt political acts
youtube says well no we actually don't
follow those laws we actually don't
if it's slander or libel sometimes
they'll leave it up we've had
shows with youtube where we've
interviewed people they have been on
camera
saying i give permission spelling out
their name on camera right release forms
and then they went afterwards and said i
didn't like the way that i looked
i want you to remove it and we had to
blur the face we go but that's not the
law
so they they don't follow the laws that
we should all agree
yeah whether we agree with the laws or
not we all agree that since they are
law need to be enforced they operate
outside of the law
and then they create their own new laws
while benefiting from the legal
protection of 230.
how could you ever catch a corrupt
politician
dark money in politics if this is the
standard they use and of course it's not
a standard that they apply equally
it's oh a liberal doesn't like it so
we're going to remove this
all someone needs to say is yeah you
know what i did offer money for that uh
that underage uh boy of the night but uh
i didn't like the way that clip made me
look and i want you to remove it youtube
says good enough for me
and then they let the matt get stories
roll for you know so this
this this point is so important because
yeah we all agree there are there are
standards and we
have laws for those standards and okay
good that's like how society is supposed
to work right
and then youtube says nah never mind
we're going to have our own
it's actually i don't even just mean to
single out youtube it's all of these
corporations and specifically big tech
they say no
we're gonna we're gonna kind of pass our
own laws and actually
cocaine mitch himself as
establishmentarian as you get on the
right
mitch mcconnell came out and he said
this is a big threat
because these woke corporations are
operating
like a parallel government they are in
many ways
the real governing force in the country
and they look i don't like big
government
but i i also don't like big corporation
because they're even less accountable to
the people than the government is
well yeah and they're more powerful than
any government's ever existed if you
were to actually
get in a delorean and go back to the
roman empire and show caesar the power
of alphabet google youtube and show them
the map and how much information is
controlled i think you're kidding me
caligula would be like that's a little
extreme whoa guys
i just i just you know was seeing a few
ladies in the brass room here
well by the way it looks like that
epstein picture no one was allowed to
cover that until uh he uh
he died under a security camera footage
that went out for the exact 12 minutes
right
but the point is yeah no these people
are more powerful than government and i
do think that people need to understand
it's not just
it's not about private corporations at
this point yeah um it's not about an
open market when they collude
and when they don't follow the laws and
they enjoy the legal protections that by
the way other business owners
out there don't if you post something at
daily wire
and it is incorrect and it is malicious
and it is slander
you can be sued you will be sued and you
will lose
we have been sued and we've won and it
cost us money just to win because
someone says i don't like the article
that you're they would never dream of
suing youtube because of these
protections of 230. one other thing i
would like to talk about i don't know
how much time we have
yeah we have at least like 10 seconds
left yeah okay
well thank you i appreciate it you're
you're busy man
um and next time i will bring you the
cigars when i'm not you know kind of
you know just to let let the audience in
a little bit we were supposed to hang
out this week i was very excited you
were going to bring some stogies we were
gonna
we're gonna have a great time uh
obviously stephen had you exercised your
lungs
properly you probably wouldn't be in
this uh this
sickness right now i knew i need to make
better choices
[Music]
i think this is because a lot of
liberals even if you say oh you know
what basic conservative
even though you acknowledge it not
extreme yeah still don't like his
opinion get rid of it guess what
you won't be able to conduct any sort of
business at all
in the world really uh without access to
facebook youtube amazon google alphabet
you know google youtube
um this is also a business issue for
people who own and run a business
we just talked about how we've
advertised on uh on youtube or on
facebook right and
i don't have i'm entirely independent
right and we have sort of partnerships
so
i haven't adverti i haven't spent nearly
as much money as other people yeah but
i've done it consistently to understand
how the systems work from both sides
and you know they send you these these
they send you these requests and you get
someone on the phone who says hey
advertise with us as opposed to
billboards they
have this whole kind of spread right you
get to keep the subscribers you gain you
get to keep the followers that you have
they encourage you to spend your money
as a business
on these platforms and then they decide
which businesses they're going to allow
through and which businesses are going
to
pinch the valve to give you an idea
what's the vox apocalypse who's vox
nbc vox disney universal viacom
vox they've co-produced a show with
youtube and netflix right this is some
people need to understand in original
studios
it wasn't just us versus some
independent online video creators
it was us versus one of the biggest
multimedia conglomerates
that has existed before big tech and
then you go through a period
where you searched steven crowder
changed my mind abortion and you can't
find it go on
instead you find nbc videos and this is
what's really concerning
um for anyone out there who runs a
business it's taking away your ability
to put up flyers for guitar lessons to
give an idea as to how we've had to
change
our business people uh online
we just you know used to upload the
shows let the cars fail where they may
well then we realized oh hold on a
second we're not really showing we're
not being able to reach people search
browse people are entering in
the title of the video and being taken
to a nine-year-old pbs video with
400 plays yeah so we said okay then we
need to focus on subscriptions
notifications but then notifications and
subscriptions don't always really work
and so youtube doesn't really tell you
why they don't work
so what we had to do at this point
because youtube is favoring live
streaming
we live stream and we just tell everyone
we've gone back to the old school johnny
carson approach
weekdays at 10 a.m eastern just bookmark
it and tune in so we don't lose touch
with you
so it doesn't matter if notifications
work it doesn't matter if search or
browse works
we still have millions of people tuning
in no matter what and if you go on the
youtube live
page we're number one two and four out
of five
in any given day i think that's a huge
component to it because if i were seth
meyers
and even even though i was getting all
that auto play i'd be
pretty pissed but we constantly have to
reinvent the business model that is
different from the terms we agreed to
when we spent money and everyone here
their livelihoods depend on it like i
said
just want to know the rule book and
anyone who says they know the rule book
is being dishonest you know i know
because youtube has said we don't show
you the rulebook yeah
i don't know if they know the rule book
this i'm so glad you brought this up
because
yes there's the ideological point they
don't like our views and so
they're going to support the leftist
fuse too but there's a money component
here too
you're taking away eyeballs and you're
taking away dollars
from the left-wingers who can't get the
same kind of views and there's a lot of
a
moneyed interest here that is trying to
get those eyeballs back
you know we've got eyeballs we got to
work on we've got lungs that we got to
work on next time
i hope that we can exercise those lungs
with those stogies
when you are feeling better hopefully
when you're back on youtube
in the meantime though seriously people
need to go
to the mug club because i got to tell
you pal look i hope it all works out
i think you're you're big enough in the
sense that it would be a really big deal
if they if they took you off totally
but right it would be bad for you it
would be bad for the audience and
most importantly it would be bad for me
and all the rest of the conservatives
out here who are trying to get a message
out
because if they come for you and it
really seems like they are they're
coming for all of us that's just the way
oh you don't have a chance not a chance
catholic boy like you no chance
whatsoever
especially i don't know if you've been
vaccinated or not yet but you have
absolutely no chance
and i think we share the same views here
um
look i'm pro-business i'm anti-fraud
that's really what it comes down to it's
about business practices
give us the rule book and i do have to
correct you we won't be exercising our
lungs when i come out because you don't
inhale stogies
that's no you're right only every you're
right it's it
i actually got someone wrote in to me
today and they said michael should i
take up smoking cigars i'm told they're
really bad for you
and i said yeah well you don't inhale
you know you're all good you know it's
like bill clinton you don't inhale
they said well but it's bad for your
mouth and your lips and you're this and
you're that i said you know look man
to quote a great liberal economist in
the long run we're all dead isn't that
the case so
we gotta we gotta enjoy ourselves a
little bit uh we'll either be dead well
physically we'll
all be dead someday digitally uh we may
be dead sooner rather than later
if big tech gets its way uh before that
happens
everyone head on over to the mug club
find stephen well you can on audio by
the way
people can still listen on audio on
apple on android on spotify and it's it
doesn't
you know listen it's a video show so
that's one thing we often you know we
try and direct people to watch the video
on mug
there's also an additional hour but yeah
people can listen on audio just
don't let us lose touch with you guys
out there um so
somewhere sign up either mud club if you
don't have the money we still provide
plenty of free content on audio
and yes i am dead inside yeah and i will
i will say before we go very quickly
if by the time this video goes up if
youtube has
permanently banned stephen crowder i
never liked him anyway i don't know him
i don't please don't associate me with
him at all we have nothing to do i
disavow his views
his vicious vile awful please yeah don't
take me down well i just hate it i just
i gotta i just hated that michael
knowles told me to never get the vaccine
what was that
no no no hold on no please no stephen
crowder everybody thank you for watching
[Music]
you